there is an
uneasy calm in delhi kept by
hundreds of police and paramilitary
it has come late at least 35 people have
died
and over 200 injured in the worst
communal rights in decades
travel began between the hindu majority
and muslim minority over the
controversial citizens law
brought in by the nationalist government
under prime minister modi
this is what's left of the family
business of muhammad azad and his
brother
the shops vandalized and set a light
everything is destroyed
the families lived above the shop and
had to flee
when the fire began spreading it's a
tear gas
assault this is a tear
gas fired on us he tells me i've been
hit too
his home now in cinders there is nothing
to salvage as he shows me around
he says my lifetime earnings are all
butting
ashes i am totally destroyed
my home is unsafe i can't stay here
where am i to go policing of the cities
under the federal government
the force has come under severe
criticism of being ineffective
in providing security in muslim areas
this is one of the most sensitive areas
of of northeast delhi where there's been
communal clashes and now we're seeing
regular flag marches by the police out
here to maintain peace
with more paramilitary and police
deployed the trouble has been put
under control for now we have been to
very narrow streets and everywhere
everything is peaceful absolutely
in a few weeks a wedding was to take
place in rajya's home
two days ago it was satellite
everything in ruin now
they frightened us so much we can't live
the peace between the communities has
been ripped
the minorities here live in fear and
with the right-wing nationalist
government
this concern grows never lazarus
sky news delhi